this sports gods up in the clouds in
another dimension we join them now at
their monthly meeting alright before we
get started just a reminder guys we need
to make sure we sync up before doling
out injuries okay the Patrick Kane
Derrick Rose situation Chicago starting
to get suspicious and I'm getting some
flak from upstairs so like seriously
guys but the cane injury was on the
calendar yeah my bad
Rose breaks easily his MCL wasn't
scheduled to snap for another two weeks
it listen it happens guys it happens
it's fine what's really important is
that March is upon us and I'm just
wondering does anyone have any crazy
sports events happening in March anyone
bowling I have something going on I
don't think so were you fencing is there
a big fancy thing not that I'm aware of
what am I thinking of then I must be
going mad much madness yes
all right college basketball I think
there's some very excited gods who want
to know what kind of madness you've got
it store for this year madness March
Madness it's a funny thing madness what
does it even mean it's the question I
asked myself two weeks ago when I set
off on my madness journey a man this
journey what's a madness journey I don't
know it sounds good
I sought out some consultants if you
will to teach me what it truly meant to
be mad Howard Hughes Nietzsche Edgar
Allen Poe oh yeah go Ravens I get it
you read one thing in high school uh not
true I've actually read quite a few Matt
Christopher books tough to tackle anyone
it's incredible if you shut up in my
conversations I found that my question
itself
what is madness had no meaning I began
to question the meaning of meaning what
is meaning what is the point
uh yeah I'm hoping there is a point here
college basketball I mean really it's
all just a Shakespearean tragedy folks
one that's masquerading as a tournament
where one minute get the most
outstanding player and the next you're
in Sioux Falls trying to claw your way
out of the d-league
and that's when you realize that your
whole life is a busted bracket so this
should I not pick Gonzaga is that what
you're saying okay yeah just go with
Kentucky
uh college basketball I appreciate the
research you put in here and your
passion but I think we just want to know
who we should pick in our brackets
around Jesus Christ you know friggin
nutso to tell us the Wichita state's
gonna make the sweet 16
enough with your ablest mansplaining you
are not even listening this is it
there's no purpose there is no truth how
can there be buzzer beaters if time
isn't linear all right I think we need
to wrap this up CBI think tennis is
about tough conniption over there
tennis don't be upset sports are
important the whole point of sports is
to distract people from the
meaninglessness of yeah so they can have
fun filling out brackets all right so
moving on golf tell us about the Masters
well if you don't know about Graham
McDowell short games fasten your seat
belts 2015 is gonna be the year of the
putt
[Music]